welcome back to cbs this morning
president biden could see a u.s
intelligence report today
on the origins of the coronavirus which
he ordered nearly 90 days ago beyond the
debate over how the pandemic started is
a dispute over where it began beijing is
waging a campaign to blame the u.s for
the outbreak that was first reported in
the chinese city of wuhan raymian
ascencio has more
good morning beijing is angry and
criticisms of that u.s intel report are
getting more shrill in these final few
days one attack line is that washington
is making up lies to further support the
wuhan lab leak theory and pushback is
everywhere in china even physically with
our cbs news team on the ground
is a sensitive topic in china these men
stopped our cbs camera crew from
interviewing wuhan native zhanghai last
week putting him under a de facto house
arrest and blocking anyone from getting
in or out we last met him in person in
january as he dared sue the government
his father died from coven he's been
told to shut up if journalists came
calling
later via zoom he told us he believes
wuhan is where kovid began this kind of
talk is like treason against beijing's
official narrative despite the world's
first known covet cases being recorded
there there is a conspiracy
try to pinpoint the origin to china
victor gao is a long time china foreign
affairs commentator this virus existed
earlier than the outbreak of
in other parts of the world
including
most
logically in the united states
centering on fort detrick few in the u.s
know about the now closed center of the
u.s bio weapons program near washington
d.c
but in china fort detrick is famous even
a rap song demands it be investigated
yang xiyu at china's institute of
international studies claims there's
proof kovitz started outside china you
cannot say it's impossible from
europe impossible from the united states
and the who has been barred from
returning to wuhan after their first
visit in january furthering complaints
beyond china's borders over lack of
access and transparency do you think the
world health organization should be
allowed to go back in if the seventh
second investigation
doesn't provide the evidence about what
lab then you will require the third even
the fourth in short no and the
propaganda is working
the w.h.o is bullying the chinese people
this person told cbs news in wuhan
the u.s is trying to shift blame to
china says another
a third told us the u.s brought kovit
here during cbs's time in wuhan these
same vehicles followed our crew all
three days of filming the same men
sitting in the hotel lobby trying to
take photos knowing not everyone accepts
the communist party line like zhanghai a
frequent target of china's surveillance
campaign
i hope the u.s investigation will lead
to chinese officials getting punished
and families of victims finally finding
comfort
but it's unclear when or what the public
might see from that coronavirus origin
report beijing will no doubt attack any
criticisms and will likely keep pushing
their anywhere but china narrative about
markovic truly began
that was remy you know reporting from
china and keeping his cool is being
followed around the country trying to
report on the origin of this virus
pretty creepy when you're here when
you're in the field like that and the
people just sitting in the lobby as
you're walking around all the time all
the time very scary stuff